[Music]
welcome back
so in this series we have kind of broken
up the gigantic field of reinforcement
learning into a number of subfields
so model based reinforcement learning
model free reinforcement learning on
policy off policy gradient based
gradient free
and today we're going to be specifically
talking about model-based reinforcement
learning this is uh has a really rich
history
in optimization theory dynamic
programming nonlinear dynamics
a lot of this came about from richard
bellman's bellman optimality condition
and
dynamic programming so bellman made a
huge huge impact to the field
coming up with these kind of optimality
problems showing when you can solve
subproblems and still get a globally
optimal solution
and those are still being used today in
these policy iteration and value
iteration algorithms and in optimal
nonlinear control using the hamilton
jacobi bellman equation
so specifically today we're going to
zoom in on this block here and so we'll
be talking about
how do you kind of
iteratively optimize a policy or a value
function
by solving sub-problems
with dynamic programming and so this is
in the context of a markov decision
process we assume that the environment
that our agent is interacting with is a
markov decision process so some
probabilistic state transition process
okay and i'm going to jump in
[Music]
to give you the details of dynamic
programming and policy iteration and
value iteration i first want to just
recap the really really basic stuff for
reinforcement learning in case you're
just tuning in
uh so our agent is interacting with an
environment it senses its state through
a series of measurements s at time one
time two time three this is an iterative
measurement process we're assuming a
discrete
system like playing a game of chess
where it's turn based
and at each time i get to decide on an
action to take a
to try to hopefully maximize my future
reward
for this game
and we are trying to design an optimal
policy pie again that gives us the
maximum future rewards
we have this value function v that um
given our policy pi it tells us how
advantageous is it what is the the
expected future rewards of being in this
state now and enacting this policy pie
and it's a probabilistic uh
process so we're taking the expected
value of our future rewards given some
policy pie
and i don't know the best policy or the
true value function for that best policy
out of the gate that's what i'm trying
to learn i'm trying to learn the optimal
policy and ideally also an optimal value
function for what is the best state to
be in
what we do assume that we know at the
the outset at least for this model based
reinforcement learning for kind of the
simplistic version
is we assume that we have a model for
how the environment works how the system
works
so we assume that the environment
evolves according to a markov decision
process
so that would be this probability here
so the probability that the state of my
system at the next time step will be s
prime
is some some probability
based on or conditioned on my state
currently being s and my current action
being a
so given a current state s and a current
action a there is some probability that
my system will transition to a new state
s prime and that's encapsulated in this
probability model p
this is called a markov decision process
and it generalizes a normal markov
process to have this action or control
input a
we also assume that we have some model
of what the reward structure looks like
so what is the probability of a reward
given some
current state s
sorry given given a current state s and
a current action a
and assuming that i move to a future
state s prime in the next state
what is my expected reward uh given all
of that happening so given kind of this
information what is my expected reward
uh at the next time step
and again this is kind of an assumption
that you know the rules of the game
you're playing so if i'm playing chess
for example you know the reward only
comes at the very end of the game but i
know what the rules to win are i know
how to checkmate someone or how to not
checkmate someone you have to know that
going in to play
and so um
this would basically say i know what my
reward is given a current you know like
given a future state
and so this is the information we have
at the outset and we're trying to learn
an optimal policy and an optimal value
function uh that kind of
allow you to best play that game to
maximize your future rewards
good
and i'm going to walk through some
properties of the value function that
allow you to solve this problem this
seems like a big brute force problem let
me let me take one step before i go into
the value function
in the game of chess for example there
are so many possible boards
configurations the state s there are so
many possible states that your
chessboard can be in something like you
know 10 to the 80. in fact fun fact
the number of possible
boards of chess that you can have is an
unknown number we know that it's very
large you know 10 to the 80 or something
on the order but we don't know exactly
what that number is
and i think that's kind of
a fun fun fact that we know it's huge
but we can't actually perfectly quantify
what that number is
uh it has someone famous name
but but that's neither here nor there
and so
we can't actually compute this optimal
value function at all of those 10 to the
80 board conditions
so um
to solve for the optimal policy and to
get this optimal value function would be
a combinatorial like brute force search
over all possible states and it just
isn't even remotely feasible okay so we
need some alternative
and
that's what the dynamic programming is
going to allow us to do is to break this
up into smaller sub-problems so that i
can think of like what's the optimal
thing to do for three steps ahead or for
four steps ahead or for five steps ahead
that's actually how you know you learn
to play when you're a kid is you think a
couple moves ahead and you optimize for
that that's what dynamic programming
allow us to do break this up into
smaller sub problems
okay and so again the goal is always to
optimize the policy to maximize future
rewards that's all i can do as an agent
so we start with this value function
given some policy pi the value function
at a given state s is my expected future
reward
discounted potentially by some gamma
factor so this gamma is a number between
zero and one that discounts future
rewards over current rewards and that's
kind of an economic principle
there's
results that show certain optimality and
convergence criteria for this kind of
exponential decaying reward function
but that's what the value function does
is it basically adds up your expected
future reward be given that you're in a
state s now
and you know your first state is s and
you enact an optimal policy pi
so it's kind of an implicit function of
pi
and if i drop the subscript pi if i just
talk about the value function capital v
then this capital v value function is
the value of being in a state s assuming
that i am working on the
absolute best possible policy
again for any game that you can name
like chess or go like most games you
have no idea what this best policy is
but there is some hypothetical best
policy pie
and if you always played that best
possible policy pi
this v would be the value of being in a
particular state assuming you do the
best thing possible
good
uh and one of the really really cool
things so this is what bellman figured
out uh richard bellman kind of the rest
was history he figured this property out
that allowed him to invent dynamic
programming uh and a large part of the
field of reinforcement learning
so this value function here this exact
expression
you can take this sum of future rewards
and break it up into the current reward
at time step now
zero means you know now
plus all of the future rewards starting
at time step one to infinity that you
know so i take my my sum of all of my
rewards at time now to infinity
and i break that up into my reward now
plus the sum of all of the rewards at
the next state to infinity
so now
this is uh
this is the reward given that my current
state at time now is s
this
is my reward
given that my next state s1 at the next
time step is s prime
and so what this allows you to do is
essentially rewrite your value function
your value function
given the best policy possible
is whatever your current reward is
plus a discounted value function
at this next state s
and so you can recursively define your
value function like this my value
function at my current state
is a function is a function
of the value function at my next state s
prime
and that's really really powerful so
this means that if i do the absolute if
i know what this value function is and i
know what the best next state is
all i have to do is take an action now
to get me to that next best state
in the future and so this is a recursive
expression that allows you to break it
up into sub problems this is called
bellman's equation or bellman's
optimality condition
and if this is satisfied for a problem
if the the value function the thing
you're trying to optimize is a recursive
function of itself at the next time step
you can break this problem up into sub
problems you can optimize locally and if
you optimize locally enough and all of
these different states and you put them
together you still have an optimal
solution so basically i can optimize
this sub problem and then plug it into
this problem and it's still optimal
that's really simple but very powerful
and once i have my optimal value
function so assuming that i just you
know i i did this and i had this optimal
value function and i maybe someone
handed me an optimal value function
then i can always extract from this
this expression here this optimal value
function i can always expect
extract the policy pi as the pi that
maximizes this expected reward
it's a little
circular here we're maximizing over the
policy pi this expression
argmax means the pi that maximizes this
expression so you can always extract a
policy from a value function
okay and given a policy you can create a
value function
so this is bellman's equation and this
is the basis of dynamic programming
so dynamic programming is how we solve
uh how we we build up this value
function again we assume we know the
rules of the game but we don't know the
value function or the optimal policy pi
and so we can build this up even for
complex games using dynamic programming
as long as this equation is true
and it's true for markov decision
processes
so what richard bellman said
is essentially given systems that are
recursive sub problems like this you can
break them up
this multi-step optimization problem
like how do i make a sequence of chess
moves to win a game
i can break that up into a number of
smaller sub-problems
where if i optimize over those sub
problems and then i put them all
together i still have an optimal
action policy policy
and there you know there's a lot of
details of dynamic programming kind of
how you program this up in a computer
how you actually do this
maybe that'll be you know a detailed
lecture for another day
there are kind of two big approaches
there is the top-down approach and the
bottom-up approach
and so in the top-down approach you
essentially
list out all possible sub-problems you
kind of list out all possible little
sub-problems and you try to solve all of
them and you basically just keep track
every time you need a sub-problem you
see if it has been solved if so you use
it if not you solve it and recursively
you end up filling out this table
of subproblems until eventually you've
kind of brute force solved the whole
thing
i'll point out you can't solve chess
using dynamic programming it's too big
you have to use other approximate
methods
things like deep learning and things
like that but it's it's a good cartoon
you can solve tic-tac-toe using dynamic
programming that's one of my homework
exercises
so the top-down approach is basically to
create this table or memoization of all
sub-problems and solve them as needed
until they're all solved
um
[Music]
the bottom-up approach
is basically to um
always start with the smallest
sub-problems and work your way back
aggregating them into bigger problems
so the way you would think about that is
you would start from every winning
configuration every configuration where
you definitely got a reward and won
and then you'd optimize one step back
what was the best move to get me in that
position and then you'd optimize two
steps back what was the best
move given that i want to be here to get
me in that position and you'd kind of
recursively build up bigger and bigger
optimization sequence from from these
winning configurations or from locations
where you know you're getting a reward
this is a massive simplification but
that's the basic idea of dynamic
programming
[Music]
and although it's still very expensive
and kind of a brute force approach it's
still better than a naive brute force
approach
um dynamic programming is really closely
related for those of you who are
computer science people it's closely
related to divide and conquer methods
except that divide and conquer methods
like
the quick sort algorithm
specifically rely on your problem being
non-overlapping and non-recursive
whereas these are this is a recursive
optimization so this is a bit more
sophisticated
okay that was a lot so now let's talk
about how we actually do this uh for
value iteration for example
so two of the the leading algorithms
that rely on dynamic programming for
model-based reinforcement learning are
value iteration and policy iteration and
so value iteration is essentially going
to allow me to use bellman's optimality
condition
to iteratively build a refined estimate
of myvalue function through trial and
error
not through trial and error through
optimizing
a sequence of events through a known
model
and there's ways of tweaking this so
that you can do it through trial and
error that's called approximate dynamic
programming
and i'll talk about that later
so the idea is that the value function
again we're trying to maximize over the
best all the possible actions we're
maximizing that action
to give this optimal future reward and
so it's my reward now plus a discounted
value function at the next step in my
model given that action a
and i'm you know i have to sum up over
these probabilities because this is a
markov decision process so if this was a
deterministic process
you wouldn't have this sum and this
probability but this is essentially
necessary because this is a
probabilistic markov process
but this is the thing we're trying to
maximize over is our future total reward
which is my reward now given this action
i'm about to take
and my future value
function my the sum of all my future
rewards discounted by gamma
that's just
this is literally just this here
rewritten
and so uh what we're essentially going
to do
is
kind of iteratively
start to update this v given this
situation so we're going to in every sub
problem
assuming that i have this assumes two
things
it assumes that i know the model of
where i will be given an action uh
in my from my current state
and it assumes that i know v
at my next state
so i basically create a big table of my
value function at all of the possible
states
and i might initialize it at zero or
random or whatever
and then what i do is i start at a state
some initial i randomly pick a state i i
start there
and i start kind of playing the game i
start running through
action sequences and updating my
estimate of the value function so let's
see how this works
i'm in a state s now
and what i'm going to do
i actually can evaluate this function
for all actions
because i know the reward function i
know the model p
and i at least have a table of what i
think the optimal value function is at
all next states
now that might be a really crummy
estimate this is kind of a v hat this is
an estimate of the value function it
might be a garbage estimate but it's
something that's the best i got
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to maximize over all actions i'm going
to compute this for all actions and pick
the best action
that gives me the maximum possible value
assuming this
bad estimate here
and i'm going to update the value
function at this current state s that
i'm currently at i'm going to take my
table find my current state and i'm
going to update that value function with
this maximum
expected future reward
then i take the next step
and i do the whole process again now i'm
in a new state
and i find the best action
you know this assumes that i have some
estimate of what my value function is at
the next state and i do this again and
again and again
and even if this value function was
initialized badly
when i run through this time and time
and time again i'm going to iterate
through this that's why it's called
policy iteration i i i iterate through
the game i play a game of chess i play
another game of chess and another one
and another one and another one
and
each time i'm updating my value function
based on what i think is the best action
this is on policy if you like
and so
eventually that value function starts to
get better and better and better and the
better the value function gets the
better i'm able to update my value
function because
you know this is a recursive formula
it's a it's a really simple idea because
it's recursive i can just initialize
everything poorly and then iteratively
kind of refine that value function as i
play the game and play the game and play
the game and i'm kind of virtually
playing the game you know a simulated
version because i know the rules and i
know the probability here
so this has to be you have to have a
model to do this value iteration you
need to know p
and you need to know what is the
expected s prime the next state
given that p
now in this case once i've done this so
i iterate over my policy i play a game
and then i reiterate i play another game
and i play another game maybe i start
from different random board positions
and then i play and i play and i play
and i iterate until this converges to
within some tolerance
now again you can't do this for
exceedingly large problems where the
state space is you know billion or
trillion or 10 to the 80 like in chess
but for small problems like tic-tac-toe
you can actually code this up and try it
yourself okay so i highly encourage you
to
enumerate all of the states of a
tic-tac-toe board
and just initialize some crappy random
initial value to every possible state
and then run through this value
iteration some big for loop until you
refine
that estimate
and once that's converged you can then
extract the optimal policy as the a that
maximizes
this thing you've been working with
this thing here
so that's value iteration and this
relies on bellman's optimality condition
and it uses dynamic programming it's a
type of dynamic programming
so the
kind of other leading approach that was
value iteration
policy iteration is just a little bit
more complicated but also very similar
and it's a two-step iteration process so
what we do is the first thing is we lock
in a policy pi so it's whatever we think
is the best policy pi
and we iteratively update our value
function locking in that policy pi so we
do the exact same thing as before but
instead of doing the max over all
actions a we just enact our whatever we
think our best policy is
and again we
you know kind of iteratively update what
the value is for every state by walking
through different states
and seeing what happens essentially
and then we lock in that value function
after we've iterated on that we lock in
the value function
and then we sweep through
uh the actions and we try to iteratively
update the policy
so that given a state s we can take the
best actions a that maximize our future
rewards
now again that assumes that i have a
good working model of my value function
at this state and at all future states
at the next state s prime
now again this might be a like this
might be a bad approximation of the
value function here but it's usually
good enough to improve my policy
then once i improve my policy i lock my
policy and i do another value iteration
step and that might be still a crappy
policy and a bad estimate of the value
but it's good enough to improve my value
function and now based on that better
value function i lock that in and i
improve my policy based on that policy i
improve my value function and this
iterative
procedure again you iterate until some
convergence criteria
this is a lot like
the kind of alternating
alternating directions
optimization that we see in machine
learning
so
policy iteration often converges in
fewer iterations than pure value
iteration so this is often kind of a
preferred approach in in a lot of cases
and again i would like you to try on the
game of tic-tac-toe write a program to
do value iteration write another one to
do policy iteration and compare how fast
they converge which one converges in uh
in less iterations which one's
faster you know on your cpu
so the last thing i want to point out
is that the value function v
where expect essentially you know
optimizing the
action
to maximize this future expected reward
this expectation here my reward now plus
my you know discounted all some of my
future rewards
and when i compute my policy function pi
i'm also i'm trying to maximize over
actions i'm trying to find the action
that maximizes this expectation
so it seems like there's redundant
information the value function and the
policy function both are
intimately depending on this expectation
of all future rewards here and so it
turns out you can introduce something
called the quality function this q
function
which is the quality of being jointly in
a state s and taking an action a
and literally this quality function is
that expectation
from before so this expectation that
we're we're trying to to estimate with
our value function or exploit with our
policy
is the quality function
it is the expected
future current and future rewards
given a state s and an action a
now the q function it seems like i've
just renamed something i've already
worked with and i have
but this is super super important
because when i did policy iteration and
value iteration i needed to have a model
of what my future
state s prime is so that i could uh use
this value at that next state in my
optimization and my recursive dynamic
programming optimization
whereas in the quality function if i
start to learn a quality function q of s
and a
all of this information is implicitly in
this function
and so i can optimize directly and learn
and iterate this quality function and
iteratively improve it
and i don't need a model for what my
next state is because it's already
implicitly defined in the quality
function
that's a subtle point but this quality
function just writing it so it's
implicitly a function of the future
state
instead of an explicit function
means that i can do uh model-free
reinforcement learning i can optimize
this quantity directly without knowing
what my future state is going to be i
can do this by trial and error
and again from this quality function
once i learn a good quality function i
can extract my value function or my
policy pi from this q function so this
has all the information i need to get my
value function or my optimal policy
and so uh it's evolving that lots and
lots of modern reinforcement learning
algorithms really do rely on this
quality function so you have these deep
quality networks
that have been revolutionary in playing
uh atari games so deepmind's atari game
is a deep quality network
um
the early versions of uh like alphago
you know use use these quality functions
so really really powerful powerful stuff
here
okay we've talked about this block here
where if we have a markov decision
process we can do policy iteration or
value iteration leveraging dynamic
programming and bellman optimality and
we've also shown how this quality
function queue
kind of
incorporates all of this information but
hopefully in a way that we can use for
model free control so we'll talk about
that
later all right thank you